adding a glazed ham to your holiday menu
is a great way to get ahead it's
delicious versatile and the ultimate
dish to have in the fridge for any
hungry guests who drop by
Christmas would never be the same
without a beautiful delicious honey
glazed ham across that long Christmas
period this can get you out of jail
quite easily ham salads ham sandwiches
Hamburg and chips the
is a Gammon what we can do now is cook
it so it becomes a ham
in Japan
first things first the water
cover it completely so the whole Gammon
Cooks evenly
the important part now is adding flavor
in there
carrots in
the leaks the more veg in there now the
more fragrant the broth becomes once the
ham is cooked that stock is
extraordinary the base to a fantastic
soup onion not finely chopped and in
homemade hamstock is packed with flavor
so it's great for making soups sauces
stews and risottos plus it can be frozen
so it's there when you need it
pan down
peppercorns lightly Crush then to give
their Christmas flavor I'm adding
crushed coriander seeds two cinnamon
sticks and four aromatic bay leaves up
to the boil and then turn it down let it
simmer and then skim it
cooking a ham isn't hard but it does
take time this two kilo joint takes two
and a half hours to simmer before it's
glazed and baked however it is worth it
because it tastes absolutely delicious
so the glaze very very simple
Demerara sugar
Madeira
that sweetens the glaze basically a 45
wine
a couple of tablespoons
in
and then
show vinegar again couple of tablespoons
honey in
nice
bring that up to the ball the longer you
leave it on the stove the darker it
becomes you want your hand really nice
and dark then cook out the glaze for
three four minutes that
I'm happy with
lovely
right the gammon's cooked now onto the
plate
carefully snip the string
nice and gently peel back get rid of the
skin then crisscross it don't push too
deep let the knife do the work
stud it
close
[Music]
look at it almost looks like an albino
pineapple the glaze
and just carefully
cover start in the middle and let it
work round
oh
God
gently gently gently gently
it's not even roasted yet and it looks
amazing
beautiful
look at that half the glaze over now
into the oven
15 minutes
I started to color
look at the rest of the glaze
and pour that over
look at it wow the more effort
passion and love you show the ham now
the results are tenfold look at it every
five minutes out of the oven and glaze
again
I'm back in the oven now
a 190 degrees we're going to baste and
roast for 35 minutes
delicious
next I'm going to make a pear and
saffron Chutney this is a fruity relish
that works brilliantly with a sweet
aromatic ham
First Things First Slice the onion
[Music]
fry the chopped onion in olive oil
without coloring it the important part
about this stage is the fact that we're
going to layer the chutney with textures
from onion to Apple to pear
a nice little block of Ginger grating
the ginger so the ginger sort of
disappears with the onions
then add the spices a good grating of
nutmeg
followed by a teaspoon of cinnamon and a
teaspoon of cayenne pepper to give it a
kick delicious I recently spent a lot of
time in India where chutneys originated
and discovered that whereas the British
style chutneys tend to be cooked and are
usually quite sweet Indian ones are
normally fresh spicier and quite sour
next Demerara sugar
once that Sugar's dissolved the white
wine vinegar all in
that's going to give you this really
nice sort of sweet and sour flavor from
there our fruit
these are Williams pairs
per is the star of the Chutney so keep
it quite rustic
next add chopped cooking apples their
tanus gives a lovely contrast to the
sweetness of the pears to give it great
texture a handful of sultanas
paint your saffron this gives it a
really nice depth a rich golden color
saffron is the world's most expensive
spice it's made from the dried stigmas
of the saffron crocus flower and as a
general rule of thumb the deeper the
color of the threads the better the
quality and to make it lighter the zest
and juice of two oranges the orange and
the saffron go brilliantly well together
just squeeze that in there
This chutney's brilliant with ham
fantastic in sellers but equally as
delicious with fish whether it's a
roasted Cod a grilled fillet of mackerel
it goes brilliantly well bring it up to
the ball
cook that out for 15 minutes now
Tomatoes going at the end and that
brings a certain amount of freshness to
Chutney really helps to give it that
nice texture
[Music]
mix that in
literally cooking cooking in 30 seconds
[Music]
what's great about this Chutney is that
as it matures its flavor gets better and
better and it will keep for up to six
months
fill up the jar
and that
is going to deliver amazing flavor
across Christmas
and look my goodness me that
is Fit For A King
foreign
[Music]
listen I need some help okay we're gonna
make the most amazing pumpkin soup Phil
That's Heavy it's very heavy but it is
going to be absolutely delicious right
and I can always tell
okay if it's ripe
a little bang on there
what does that sound like
um drums that's right and if you push
your thumb in there
just a little bit of soft right at the
bottom of the root right first of all
I'm going to cut it in half and very
carefully just cut through
I'm using a French pumpkin but these
versatile vegetables come in all shapes
and sizes and colors at this time of
year their nutty sweetness is ideal for
warming soups curries and roasts wait
and see what happens when we open this
up wow
oh right Holly that's for you now this
is where it's going to get a little bit
gory okay you get your hands and you
scrape the seeds out but this is getting
messy rub them together and just give
them a little clean nice and gently good
yeah nice look at that what do you mean
yuck come on Holly that's it into the
water
now once the seeds are out we're going
to toast them in the oven as a little
snack so this is a really nice way I'm
not wasting anything
get your fingers right in there Tilly
there you go
[Music]
once the pumpkin seeds are out score the
flesh to help it roast and absorb flavor
season and had a generous amount of
Rosemary take the garlic rub around the
outside so perfumes the inside then add
a large glug of olive oil and as a
garlic roast with a rosemary it's sweet
almost buttery nutty taste or mellow and
flavor the pumpkin all the seeds done
yeah almost good
after the pumpkin seeds have been
cleaned dry and season them ready for
the oven
and they're gonna roast in the oven for
about 45 to 50 minutes
good
and when you smell the house in about
five minutes time try please Holly
so
beautiful straight in right well done
big question have you brought mommy's
present yet
quickly
oh that garlic smells amazing
[Music]
Holly Tilly where's Holly he's going to
a party she's going to a party oh no any
boys there hello I don't know I also
diplomatic right look
today
are now toasted
hear that
right have a little taste of one of
those
yeah but look at this wow that
looks amazing and that is your roasted
pumpkin now
you put the spoon down the side okay yep
scooping out well they're lovely
roast pumpkin we don't waste anything
you hear that skin all into the center
roasting a pumpkin intensifies the rich
sweet flavor of its flesh which is
lovely for Soups but also great as a
filling for ravioli or making a
delicious Mash with butter nutmeg and
salt and pepper that's the pumpkin dump
now what we need to do is get these
mushrooms here and just peel them
lengthways okay onto the plate again
I'll get my onion chopped
olive oil in
okay yeah nice and generous with olive
oil because I want this soup do really
nice and velvety onions in
[Music]
and then scoop out
how wonderful garlic has been roasted on
the pumpkin
lovely a little bit of nutmeg on top of
the onions
onions garlic nutmeg yeah and now the
pumpkin
wow
and you would come in handy somewhere
this little baby
is for you there you go perfect
now I want you just to grate some
Parmesan like that for me okay just so I
can start roasting off the parmesan as
well so we get this really nice rich
delicious
the pumpkin
Karma sounds brilliant for enriching
this soup it's mellow caramel flavor and
saltiness provide a lovely balance to
the Sweet pumpkin now what we need to do
all that in there okay
yeah good
[Music]
look at that now
that ah
smell that
roasted sort of cheesy Rosemary garlicky
yeah Olive oily beautiful so far
nothing's gone to waste we've used the
whole pumpkin now I'm gonna add the
stock my ham was cooked in
doesn't it smells Christmassy delicious
just from cooking our ham
bring that up to the boil
and let that cook out for 10 minutes
cream really important that it's boiling
when the cream goes in
okay you'll see the color lightning
so that's gonna give it a really nice
rich
creamy taste okay now we're going to
show you the mushrooms who would olive
oil in there yeah
get nice and hot
we'll go first with the compa de Lamour
in you go
good girl then the pier in
and then finally Chantal nice lovely I'm
going to put a little bit of butter in
there
we go good girl a little bit better
there nice I love the Deep complex
flavor of wild mushrooms but if you
can't get them Chestnut or filled
mushrooms still deliver Great Taste
mushrooms worked really well with
pumpkin because they have a warm earthy
flavor that complements the pumpkin
beautifully so
mushrooms into the center yeah yeah
from there
we get the parmesan
and just peel nice long layers
watch very carefully not just sit that
on top on the parmesan
helps to season the mushroom
and really
give off
an amazing flavor
okay we're gonna blend the soup and all
we're going to do is half fill the
blender
so the soup gets really nicely aerated
now this is a bit of a naughty Chef's
trick a little knob of butter in there
just in top so when it Blends it gets
really nice and smooth lid on
onto the blender
and we'll just pulse it on and off first
wow and this is the moment we'll be
waiting for
just one side of the bowl
so that's Daddy's portion that
this little bit is yours now
a little taste blur it gently
[Music]